en alberta canadá la universidad blues
trata de revivir las lenguas nativas
canadienses
veronica freezer creció en una escuela
católica y con 60 años quiere volver a
conectar con sus orígenes
gatza
me criaron diciendo que no éramos
iguales que éramos inferiores a los
demás y así lo creí casi toda mi vida
según la comisión de la verdad y la
reconciliación de canadá la iglesia
practicó un genocidio cultural con
150.000 niños sacados de sus hogares
wilson little child pasó 14 años en tres
internados diferentes en marzo fue al
vaticano con una delegación que fue
recibida por el papá francisco
ya se lo dije ven a canadá te invito a
que vengas a disculparte con los
sobrevivientes de las escuelas
el momento del perdón del papa a los
indígenas ha llegado los motivos son
muchos pero especialmente fue el
descubrimiento de los restos de 215
niños en una escuela hallazgos similares
se esperan en otros centros y ser super
nand también indígena trata de
encontrarlos
los niños murieron pero luego la familia
nunca tuvo la posibilidad de cerrar ni
las respuestas que se merecían nunca
supieron donde descansaba su hijo
los supervivientes y líderes indígenas
esperan aún compensaciones financieras
recuperación de objetos personales apoyo
para llevar a la justicia a los
abusadores y publicar los registros
relacionados con las escuelas que
operaron entre 1831 y 1996